what's up everyone this is Anthony popli
I know most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain simply
the best podcasting crypto let's kick
this thing off Landon Cassill is a
professional NASCAR driver and Bitcoin
and crypto enthusiast in this
conversation we discuss what it is like
growing up to race professionally how he
broke into NASCAR what actually goes on
inside the car during a race
how Landon got into crypto and what he
is currently doing in the space today I
really enjoyed this conversation and I
hope you do as well
skirt school want to know who has the
best URL crypto com
that's right crypto com there are crypto
platform with one goal mother and mass
adoption that's why we're all here we're
trying to get crypto in every wallet
crypto comm is helping people do that
through buying earning lending and card
payment everything you could want at
crypto comm go help your boy out tell
them pomp since you download the app or
visit crypto comm pumps got you always
everyone to get into mining and didn't
know how don't worry your boy pops
gotcha
everybody got some electricity and Wi-Fi
all you got to do is go to coin mine
comm you buy a coin mine it's like an
Xbox or a PlayStation that helps you
turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
there's over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right go to coin mine comm tell
them tom sent you and thank me later as
many of you know crypto investors store
their digital assets on exchanges or in
cold storage for long term safekeeping
however this strategy doesn't help them
grow their investment holdings or build
overall wealth with the new block by
interest account users can now securely
store their Bitcoin or Ethernet block
five and receive six percent
interest paid monthly in cryptocurrency
6% is an absurdly high rate it's the
best rate in the industry I highly
suggest you go check out block by
dot-com / pop again that's block 5 comm
/ pop to sign up and start earning
crypto today Anthony pomp Leon o is a
partner at Morgan Creek Digital all
opinions expressed by pump or his guests
on this podcast are solely their
opinions and do not reflect the opinions
of Morgan Creek digital or Morgan Creek
Capital Management you should not treat
any opinion expressed by pomp as a
specific inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang bang I'm sitting here
with Landon we are in Las Vegas for a
few conferences but I want to sit down
real quick and and talk Landon and I've
actually known each other for a while
now and I think that the secret kind of
app that you're into crypto Bitcoin etc
but I figured we'd sit down and actually
talk about it so this is secret is there
ever a secret well listen some people
might be if you're professional athletes
so I don't know if secrets are allowed
in sports I don't think it has to be a
secret if there's anybody out there
that's keeping it a secret that you're
in crypto if you're an athlete I don't I
don't think you need to come on out of
the closet to hide it yeah alright what
look let's start kind of early early on
right so pretty much everyone in racing
seems to start when they're like a
little kid and there's this whole kind
of series of leagues and almost stuff
that you kind of work your way up to
NASCAR or other racing leagues what did
you do that and kind of where did you
grow up and what was your path into all
this yeah I mean ah there's really no
definitive path to NASCAR it's not like
the NFL or NBA where it's it's pretty
obvious that you start out in a peewee
football or basketball and play in high
school in college in Motorsports you can
there's a lot of different forms of
motorsports that you can start out and
and it can take you to a lot of
different places I mean there's drivers
that might start out thinking they're
gonna go Indy car racing and end up
going
NASCAR racing or vice versa I'm and for
those that don't know just separate out
at the kind of the professional level
there's an IndyCar which is more open
about racing Indy 500 yep NASCAR is car
racing car offenders Daytona 500
you have Dale Earnhardt Jeff Gordon
Jimmie Johnson
Landon Cassill plane and Cassidy I'm
from Iowa I'm from Cedar Rapids Iowa and
dirt racing is a huge thing in Iowa but
I didn't actually grow up dirt racing
because I raced in go-karts which is
pretty typical for kids between the ages
of four and twelve and I had really
raced a lot in go-karts by the time I
was 12 years old and I was kind of ready
to get into full-sized cars and and my
dad well yeah my dad didn't want to get
you know stuck racing go-karts for too
long and they're the dirt tracks in Iowa
wouldn't allow me to race until I was 16
so there's one asphalt track and see
Rapids Iowa my home town called Hawkeye
town Speedway and they allowed me to
race when I was 12 to 14 years old in
their full-size cars so that's how I
started racing on asphalt on on pavement
even though I was kind of heading down a
dirt racing path and from there there
was a Touring Series in full bodied cars
that look similar to a NASCAR type race
car
that was traveling the country and they
allowed 14 year old drivers so when I
was 14 I started traveling the country
racing and what was called the ASL a
model series okay so at 12 years old I
couldn't even reach the foot pedals okay
like what is it like being 12 and you
know your dad's saying to you hey you're
gonna get in a real car yeah you're
gonna drive on the pavement and I'm
assuming you're competing against like
but the older teenagers or adults mhm
how fast these things going the the
first full-sized car that I drove was a
what's called a IMCA modified so it's an
open-wheel car it kind of it doesn't
look like an Indy car but
to someone that doesn't know anything
about racing you might think it's closer
to an IndyCar than it is a stock car but
the front suspension and the frame
itself is like an old Monte Carlo it
just doesn't have a body on it just has
have fenders and it had about 400
horsepower and weighed 2,500 pounds and
I was 12 and I weighed about a hundred
pounds and I was racing against adults
yeah and it was um it was quite an
experience it's you know at that age you
make a lot of mistakes and the mistakes
have bigger penalties and then when
you're racing a go-kart and my dad you
really had a policy from the time I
started racing that he would support the
best you know in the ways that he could
support but I had to fix whatever I
crashed so growing up starting in those
Modifieds racing and late models now you
have a car that's fenders on it it's a
little bit easier to lean into people
maybe crash someone whether it's on
accident or on purpose
my dad would pay for it but I had to
physically fix it myself
very cool so I kind of taught me from a
young age how to how to take care of my
equipment yeah and probably I don't want
to crash because I want to fix it take
there was one time that I that I had an
incident with another driver that was
pretty intentional on my part in
retaliation and and it caused some
damage to my car
and I was 16 and my dad made me pay for
it and that was six I didn't have any
money so it's like a couple thousand
dollars and I had to pretty much use my
winnings that I had been earning to pay
for the wrecked car so I learned my
lesson yeah ensue at 12 to 14 how fast
it is cars go
but at the track that I was racing on
about a hundred hundred and ten miles an
hour at 12 years old 110 miles and yeah
yeah mid corner speeds probably 60 miles
an hour I mean you're talking about like
I said 400 horsepower you you're you
know full throttle down the
straightaways you're driving it into the
corner you have to lift you have to use
a lot of brake pressure you have to
control the car from sliding and
spinning out and you have to try to
maneuver your way around other
other cars it's not just pushing the gas
down and being flat out yeah I will
track I can't imagine going 110 driving
a stick shift
with a clutch and everything yeah Wow
all right and then the NASCAR stock cars
then you drive today those going what
220
I have gone 220 in a NASCAR race car
it's at this point in NASCAR it really
depends on the aero package that NASCAR
and the rules limitations that we have
the fastest I've gone is that Michigan
International Speedway I've gone over
220 miles an hour when we had 900
horsepower and and small spoilers for
the cars didn't have a lot of drag and I
mean that's just that's just you're just
carrying a lot of speed and yes if for a
3,000 pound car that's pretty fast it's
hard on the tires it's hard on equipment
to go that fast right now our cars go
about 200 miles an hour with race this
weekend at Texas Motor Speedway our cars
will go about 200 miles an hour and I
mean our mid-corner speeds at Texas will
be 170 580 miles an hour Wow so on the
straightaways you'll hit on average to
say about 200 miles an hour but into
those corners and turns it's really not
that big of a different mean 20 miles an
hour's 20 miles an hour but it's not
like you're going from 200 and breaking
down down yeah 50 particularly at Texas
this weekend that's because of our aero
package we have a really big spoiler our
cars make a lot of downforce and when we
have fresh new tires on the car the
weather's going to be cool this weekend
one end of the racetrack turned three
and four has a lot of banking to it and
we can run wide open through that corner
without lifting so you're talking about
you know at the end of turn at the end
of the backstretch we're you know almost
190 almost 200 miles an hour and you're
not lifting so make corner speeds are
pretty high Wow pulling two or three two
sooner going a 200 miles an hour's one
thing going two miles an hour through it
turn it's crazy it's not that bad you
know our cars our cars are built to go
that fast so they handle fairly well at
times they don't you know and that's all
relative to your competitors
but you know they're supposed to go that
fast so it's harder to drive them at 140
miles an hour because they're not making
downforce they're not making grip at 200
miles an hour that's how fast they want
to go
the real problem is when they have to
stop all of a sudden you know that's
usually when bad things happen for sure
and so let's go back to you so you're
like 16 right for 2016 you start touring
you're still in school obviously so
you're like have kind of two lives it
almost feels like and I'm assuming most
kids at school are things pretty cool
that you know you're driving 100 miles
an hour yeah ken's
well how do you get from that to NASCAR
like what does that path look like once
you kind of realize hey I want to go do
this professionally what what does that
look like so fortunately for me during
that time period and during that age the
the path that we were racing and the
Touring Series that we were racing was
was a really good path to get to NASCAR
the teams that had that were flush with
money that the manufacturers that had a
lot of money to spend on driver
development on young driver development
they were looking at asphalt late-model
racers which is what I was doing as the
the next drivers there's been like I
said the moment where I mentioned
earlier the multiple different paths you
have dirt racers and sprint car drivers
people that race in in sports cars and
road courses they can all kind of end up
in the same place but that was a time
period where the most - most prevalent
types of drivers were coming from
open-wheel midgets and sprint cars on
dirt and in late models asphalt late
models so by the time I was 16 years old
well about town I was 15 16 years old I
had been scouted by an agent I had been
signed to an agency and I was racing
6070 times a year and I signed a
contract I actually did a sort of an
audition it was kind of like a gong show
audition with with Chevrolet with 16
other drivers and they all put us in
race cars and we showed our stuff in
front of each other for four and I went
out really different tests we didn't
race but it was a test so you drove by
yourself
the track you had to rate you had to
drive the car for a certain period of
time they took a lot of notes they
looked at your data the car was
outfitted with telemetry so they looked
at your driving style they listened to
your feedback and I mean there are some
pretty impressive drivers that were in
that test Joey Logano is a NASCAR
champion was in that test he actually
was the the number one ranked driver
that came out of that test and had a
contract with Joe Gibbs Racing well from
there and that was a Chevy team at the
time I was a number two ranked driver
out of that test and I got a contract
with Hendrick Motorsports out of that
test Ryan hunter-reay Indy 500 champion
was in that test so there was some big
names back then this was over this is 12
13 years ago so but like I said I got a
contract with Hendrick Motorsports
became a test driver for Hendrick tested
Jimmie Johnson's cars Jeff Gordon's cars
went whirring when this is going on I
was 17 so you're 17 and still in school
but also being a test driver for these
guys you've got to be like these dudes
are legends
so I actually finished out I'm young for
my grade I was I'm I graduated high
school when I was 17 and so this fall it
was kind of happening in my senior going
into my senior year of high school and I
had enough credits that I was able to
finish high school in my after my first
semester and your your senior year I did
the same thing and so I moved to North
Carolina with my grandma and her and I
lived together for the first three or
four years me racing professionally and
so the the timing all worked out where
my contract with Hendrick came up the
exact same time that I was finishing
high school that's awesome and sue you
you know go from literally in the
cafeteria at high school you know all of
a sudden now you're test-driving Jeff
Gordon's cars friendship motorsport yeah
what are you doing on a day to day basis
and are you kind of like starstruck at
the time or you like hey I'm sorry I'm
here to kind of you know get into
yeah these NASCAR races and start
winning races I was pretty starstruck at
the time I mean my friend imagine one of
my first jobs at Hendrick
was to drive Jeff Gordon's Daytona 500
primary car for 2007 at a straight line
test so we used to go to proving grounds
where there was they had like runways
basically with with several miles of
straight lines and you would take the
car and you drive it in a straight line
as fast as it would go and they would
collect erudite aero data and that's how
they would build their aero maps for
their simulation models so Wow one of my
first Jobs was to drive his primary car
for the upcoming Daytona 500 I know but
in those large teams a driver has
different cars for different races or
they taking one card for each race
they're actually changing the
aerodynamics and the different
components of it but it's the same car
and kind of chassis and just changes per
race at that time there was different
cars for different races and it's still
that way now NASCAR has the rules have
kind of adapted to where NASCAR's
NASCAR's really tried to make it to
where you can run the same car at as
many times as possible but ultimately
there's there's no spending cap and
there's no limit on the car there's no
VIN number right that NASCAR tracks
there's no limit on how many times you
can run a car and the biggest teams that
have the biggest budgets what they're
really doing is building cars and and
when I say cars chassis and bodies right
so you have the chassis which is sort of
the mechanical side of it and then the
body which is the Aero side of it those
cars are unique to pretty much each
racetrack so they might have a chassis
configuration with an aero configuration
that works at five or six different
tracks they have a chassis configuration
and an aero configuration that works at
two or three other tracks that are
similar to each other they they're
probably have anywhere from nine to ten
different iterations over the 38 race
schedule that we have so a lot of what
that testing that I did was developing
the
the different arrow maps and the
simulation models you know for them to
research those cars to build those cars
I mean the biggest race teams are their
manufacturing companies so it's a it's a
huge hey there's a huge facility to
build research and build these cars so I
want to talk a little bit about it and
you've been kind enough to kind of give
me a crash course on racing really comes
down to money right yeah and money
meaning the team structures are very
unique in that unlike other sports as
you mentioned there's no spending caps
there's no kind of salary cap right type
of drivers yeah yeah and so help me
understand that there's like kind of
large cap teams I'll call them or large
gems and there's a smaller more budget
type teams on a large team side most of
these are car manufacturers or have some
relationship with a car manufacturer
talk a little bit of how that
manufacturing relationship works and
then how does that trickle down into the
the hardware or the actual yeah you know
color they can put on the track and the
advantages that brings by them having
access to that count yeah so so that's a
that's one of my most exciting things to
talk about right now in NASCAR and
though the initial conversation paints a
little bit of a bleak picture of how our
sport works and then the the the light
at the end of the tunnel is where the
sport is headed so I'll walk you through
that right now you have the biggest
teams right now like Hendrick
Motorsports Joe Gibbs Racing RCR
stewart-haas and those teams are
supported by the big auto manufacturers
Toyota Ford Chevrolet now those teams
also have the biggest sponsorships
they're the most well funded they have
the best talent the best leadership the
best engineering the best drivers and
NASCAR has a rulebook that we have to
abide by when we build our racecars but
ultimately even though those rule books
have the rulebook has really tight
tolerances we're still responsible for
building and manufacturing and designing
our cars to fit those tolerances so each
team even multiple different Chevy teams
write the car that I Drive as a
in the car that Hendrick Motorsports
this building as a Chevy each team is
responsible for their own manufacturing
process and they're responsible for
their own proprietary components so
right now the biggest teams are able to
take this support that they get from the
manufacturers which is money engineering
support you know you have manufacture
like Toyota they write a check to the
teams but they also have their own
engineering facilities where they
provide Windtunnel testing and chassis
engineering and all in research and
development support those those teams
are building racecars from scratch their
building chatzi's from scratch we don't
buy them from anywhere they're building
them from scratch they're building the
bodies they're taking the cars to the
wind tunnel they're their Rd and those
bodies or they're honing them in even if
it's to the thousands of an inch they're
building they have engineering teams
that are building simulation so these
cars are I mean it's a machine learning
is a big thing that you're the big
manufacturer because it feels like
there's a lot of data that goes into
this right but yeah it almost feels like
it's an iterative process versus more
like software development where you say
all right we have kind of our first
guess so we're gonna put that in you the
chassis and they're reiterating it
they're constantly relearning and then
going back to the manufacturing plant
which they own or they develop and and
remanufacturing new parts and pieces so
those are the teams that are having the
most success the challenge for the
smaller teams in the sport right now are
that it is it is so it's so hard to
catch up with that especially when those
big teams are subsidized by the auto
manufacturers because with auto
manufacturers are not subsidizing the
smaller teams like they are the big
teams so if you're a small team coming
into the sport it's actually more
cost-effective for you to just go to one
of those big teams and pay them a
licensing fee to use their technology
rat it so the big team takes the
resources from the auto manufacturer
plus whatever else they have and
sponsorships etc they're able to iterate
faster they you know in theory create a
competitive advantage it's better
technology etc which is okay right
it's a competition sport we want to
create a competitive advantage yep the
the flaw in that is that they're able
they're taking that competitive
advantage and they're able to sort of
suppress their competition by selling
whatever it is however much they want of
their technology back to their
competition got it right then they take
that let's say that they've made a car
that goes at a certain track 215 miles
an hour they could technically sell to a
competitive competing team technology
that makes the car go 205 miles an hour
right right and that competing team may
or may not understand that they're
buying kind of inferior technology or
configuration and the team that is the
larger team has been subsidized and has
the capital they're kind of making that
decision it sounds like there's not that
much transparency into this etc is that
accurate um well I mean there's there's
it depends on the individual
relationships with the with the larger
teams and the smaller teams I mean
there's been some there's plenty of
cases I would imagine where there isn't
much transparency and the bigger team is
is charging the smaller team a lot of
money and the smaller team may or may
not know if they're getting the most
updated parts or the most updated
technology or let's just say instead of
making assumptions let's just say then
the most in the most authentic way the
big team that has six hundred employees
and and you know spends thirty million
dollars per car that they feel is
sharing all of their information with
the smaller team that's paying for this
information
well that smaller team with lesser
employees even with all that information
still lacks the manufacturing
capabilities and and the manpower to
keep up with the iterations that the big
team has or is capable of right and then
it also they also those big teams have
leverage over those small teams to
control the price of that licensing fee
ma what's called a technical alliance in
our business so technical alliance yep
technical alliance so the big teams you
know if the small team let's just I mean
you could game theory this right I'm not
making an assumption but licious game
theory --it if a big team is selling a
technical alliance to a small team and
the small team ends up outrunning the
big team what are they gonna do they're
gonna jack up the price of their
technique
right so it's and the same goes with the
engine business the engine business is
the same way the big teams Hendrick
Motorsports
I mean they they own the engine business
so they own their engine business and
they sell they lease the engines to this
to smaller teams so there's a lot of
incentive for Hendrick Motorsports on
the engine side of things to make sure
that first of all they're getting the
best engines that they can get and then
their customers they obviously need to
build a quality product to their
customers but I mean they they control
the price of they control the price of
their own customers cost to go racing
through through their engine leases so
that's the kind of interesting dynamic
in the sport that makes it challenging
to for for upward mobility and NASCAR
for a team owner the light at the end of
the tunnel is that NASCAR's is is taking
a serious movement at changing that
model and what do they want to move to
what is that new model look like you
think NASCAR is really is they're not
just looking at they're there they're
making moves and in 2021 we're gonna be
racing with a single-source manufactured
racecar so interesting so everyone will
use the same manufactured car all the
way yeah for all of all the cars parts
and pieces it'll be it'll be sourced
from or each piece that we have to buy
will be sourced from the same place got
it and can you make changes or
adaptations or enhancements to those
parts once you get them or will it be
almost the identical car for everyone in
right now the spirit of the project is
that it will all be identical right so
our sport is competitive and we're
already tuned up to with manufacturing
plants and we're already pretty savvy
when it comes to looking in a part and
saying how can we improve this so I can
promise you that teams are gonna look at
parts that there but that they're forced
to buy right that we have to put on the
car and they're gonna figure out a way
to make it better within the rules the
rules right so I would say that
NASCAR is still has a decision to make
on how they're gonna police that and how
they're gonna make sure that parts
haven't been manipulated or compromised
and you know though I would imagine
they'll be big penalties that come with
that NASCAR is probably going to be
putting some sort of long long-term
freeze on the car so that the car can
hold its value right so that you don't
buy a car and race with it and then six
months later there's all of a sudden a
new car that we have to buy yep and then
they're also gonna put a limit on how
many cars you can own so you can't just
buy 38 cars for all 38 races
gum you might have to buy seven cars and
figure out a way to make it through the
whole season with seven car making work
got it and this is very similar so I
don't think I've ever tried it before
but I have someone that I know a
gentleman lucas de Grassi who used to be
a boy racer and and then was part of and
now races in Formula e so he has open
wheel racing for electric vehicles yeah
and if I remember correctly he had told
me that formula e everyone uses the
exact same Concord right and so it's
this idea that the advantage is not in
the equipment it is in what who's behind
the wheel right and it makes it more
competitive and therefore it actually
may not just who's behind the wheel but
but who because it's not all about the
driver even if you're in the same
everybody has the same car the same
hardware you still have a race
strategist you still have general
managers you still have pit crews right
so like in in Formula e he's they have
strategists and it's about your
communication with your team and how
well you can set the car up and how well
the driver can give feedback and and and
build a car that's balanced for the race
and and you know one of the one of the
the questions that NASCAR has to answer
to their manufacturers are where are you
gonna let the manufacturers compete
right if you're gonna standardize every
part and piece on the car
you there's still a huge marketing
incentive for Toyota to be the title
sponsor of a race team because there's
have any million race fans and 5 million
viewers on TV every week but I mean do
you want to develop some technology in
our sport and if you do where do you
want to develop that technology you have
right so like in Formula e the to my
understanding the cars are standardized
like you said but the manufacturers have
some freedom to compete with each other
in the drivetrain technology right got
it
formula e electric you know there there
there there's it's pretty reasonable for
them to think hey let's come in and use
this Motorsports platform as a way to
help develop our rav4 sure technology
speaking of that NASCAR Virgo electric
you think what's kind of those sure I
think general yeah I can see that I mean
in right now the the first phase of this
sort of single source manufactured model
is the cars and the bodies and the
chassis zand and actually they're
they're looking at some sort of spending
cap some sort of way to keep the teams
from just running away with their
funding but the second phase of it is
gonna be the engine and the powertrain
and and they're looking at some sort of
hybrid regenerative energy to use for
and conversations have been anything
from a push to pass button like you've
seen in IndyCar racing to letting the
cars run off of their electric power
source under cautions so that maybe it's
like a timeout during a basketball game
where the stadium gets quiet and you can
talk again and you can you know check
your phone it's just a lot of creative
ideas but ultimately I think NASCAR is
is very well aware of where the auto
industry is going and where they could
end up but it's hard to shake the idea
of a v8 you know I was gonna say it
feels like that's like NASCAR's like the
ultimate American sport right and in
having electric vehicles something about
it doesn't feel right right and I'm sure
in a huge race band but uh but obviously
that's where the industry goes the scene
as far has three major national series
we have two series that race cars that
are actually pretty similar to each
other the Cup Series in the Xfinity
series in the Xfinity series is kind of
like the feeder series to the Cup Series
but ultimately the cars are kind of the
same and then we have a truck series
right so it makes sense to have a truck
series you know you're selling trucks on
one end you're selling cars on the other
end
I and this is just me talking I'm not
speaking for the sport but maybe the
Xfinity series someday could be the
Eevee series right and that technology
could be there and the Cup Series could
be what it is
skirt school want to know who has the
best URL crypto comm that's right
crypto comm there crypto platform with
one goal mother mass adoption that's why
we're all here we're trying to get
crypto in every wallet crypto comm is
helping people do that through buying
earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto comm
go help your boy out
tell them pomp sense you download the
app or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an Xbox or a Playstation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right you purchase
it it shows up at your doorstep you pull
it out of the box you plug it in connect
to your Wi-Fi five minutes or less
you're mining Bitcoin all you have to do
is control it from the mobile app they
provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mind
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mine calm
tell them pomp Sencha and thank me later
one more word from our sponsor blocked
by their new interest account allows you
to securely deposit your Bitcoin or
ether at block five and receive 6%
annual interest paid monthly and
cryptocurrency this rate actually
compounds so you receive a 6.2 percent
APY which is very attractive given the
alternatives so you can actually take
your Bitcoin you can deposit it with
block Phi and get paid an interest rate
of 6% in return go check out block 5
comm slash pop again block 5 comm slash
pop to sign up and start earning
interest on your crypto today what's the
difference in the spending of the large
cap change versus the small cap change
are we talking about you know
half a billion dollars like five million
dollars or is it you know much closer
like 20 million to ten million dollars
uh you have cars at the very highest end
probably spending a million per race on
their program okay there's 38 races or
DEA races yep and then on the very low
end you probably have cars to spend a
hundred thousand a race okay so ten X
then yeah yeah you're pretty a pretty
big difference there yeah and of the
team size as you said that some of the
larger guys might have 600 employees
yeah what does that look like I'm a
lower-end
so the the largest teams that those
those are spending a million erase
probably are of that size and a team
that spending a hundred thousand a race
probably has anywhere from ten to twenty
five employees got it okay so so again
pretty material a difference there all
right so you've been doing racing for
awhile and you're in a crypto yes so how
how did you first hear about Bitcoin
crypto etc and then would you do once
you heard about it I heard I first heard
about in 2013 and really through racing
because in 2014 a good friend of mine
Josh wise who hopefully has some
listeners on this podcast know who Josh
wise is because he drove the dogecoin
sponsored car in in NASCAR and the the
dogecoin community on reddit came
together and crowd funded sponsorship
for race car and they even they even
believe it or not this is crazy asses
and this is why the inner the internet
is undefeated they crowd funded the fan
vote to get him into the all-star race
ruh and they beat Danica Patrick to to
get Josh into the all-star race josh is
a very close friend of mine and I was I
was you know really shotgun with him
through this whole process because how
much did they have to crowdfund to get
the sponsorship
I think they raised six figures over the
course of all of the stuff that they did
I think they spent they those the
community came up with $100,000 at least
why
yeah so and it was it was a huge impact
on his team at the time I mean his team
had no sponsorship and they filled some
major gaps in the schedule and it was
really good for Josh you know yeah so I
was really I loved it I was super into
it and and that was my first intro to
cryptocurrency and I've never had anyone
come on it so yeah somebody introduced
us to dogecoin yeah well I mean look man
it's that honestly that that that's just
proves you the the power of energy and
positive energy a community which is the
maybe one of the core tenants of crypto
right now one of the Foundation's it's
that keeps it together but for me I you
know once I once I understood you my
first impression of Bitcoin was this
this you know online money right and and
I didn't really get it but once I
understood the financial sovereignty
side of it I was like pretty interesting
yeah you know I was pretty interested in
it and I you know really early on I
looked at day trading and and the
markets and I saw it as buying stocks or
selling stocks and and fortunately I
think I was smart enough to say that's
not what I was getting to and that's not
what I can do and and I could probably
teach myself or learn but that I don't
even want to take the time to do that
so I bought and held and I'm I'm a
pretty persistent Hodler of Bitcoin and
I but where I got myself involved more
actively was in the mining side of
things so yep so we've talked about it a
lot of mine bitcoin and litecoin and
I've done it for a little while now and
it's it's it's paid off well at times
and and they've it's been a struggle at
other times and it's I think ultimately
it's taught me a lot about
the space because it's kept me engaged
in the space as opposed to just you know
hiding my keys and forgetting about it
and then checking the price six months
later so it's kept me engaged it's
helping me network and build
relationships like the one that we have
and and other relationships that I have
and ultimately for me my involvement in
the crypto space has the potential for
anything other than just you know my
specific investment in Bitcoin but the
potential to work with companies in the
crypt of spaces they've become bigger
and have marketing needs or or want to
be involved and have you know advisors
or whatever you know be in the companies
and so when you first saw my well what
caught your attention about it Riggs
it's not like probably anything else
that that you've seen and also it takes
a little bit more sophistication to like
buy the hardware I mean how do I
actually set this how do I monitor it or
kind of feel make sure that it's working
correctly that's not like had just
signed up for a coin base account and I
just you know Leonard let him market
right order over it
and just bought some Bitcoin yeah so
what was kind of the thing that drew you
into the mining side and then you know
did you have technical background in
terms of understand some stuff or did
you have to really go kind of learn how
to how to set it up I'm not I didn't
have a ton of technical background I'm
not a total computer nerd although in
high school I was a teacher's assistant
to the IT director at my high school and
one of the jobs that I did for most of
the time that I was the TA was help set
up the networks that are at our school
so as of you know for a teenager of
having a very basic understanding of how
computers are connected and how they
operate on a network I'm a head of like
a very surface level understanding but I
think the reason that I was attracted to
mining was because it seemed it seemed
tangible and mechanical to me in a way
that I understand how things work I
seemed like it was something that I
could understand how it worked even
though computers can be confusing and
networks can be confusing the operations
of computer performance and power usage
and the the fluctuation of price and and
the flow of of production that that
seemed very I don't know it seemed like
I could identify with that and it and
also I seem like to me Bitcoin mining
was a it's a blue-collar gig you know
and and in a lot of ways and I kinda
identify with that too so I felt like
that was something where I was I could
be involved in that and that could be
where I get like I said I I'm hooked
into the space but I'm not necessarily
over my head yeah for sure and so as you
look at it in terms of the the
intersection of racing and crypto
there's obviously the sponsorship angle
right there's plenty of crypto company
that would love to sponsor the racecar
drivers or whatever
are there other elements of either
things that NASCAR is doing today or
things you can do in the future where
you see some sort of intersection with
the currencies or applications of
blockchain technology or do you think
it's more of yes probably a stick in the
sponsorship area for a while and then
maybe down the road that could happen
but probably not likely in the short
term um I mean yeah so obviously right
now sponsorship is a is a perfect Avenue
for that and that's you know no
different than it's a great idea for for
crypto companies to be involved in any
sports league or any influencer you know
NASCAR from a sponsorship perspective I
will say that I feel like NASCAR shares
a lot of the same core values that
people in the cryptocurrency world share
so as these as these crypto companies
mature to the point that they're ready
to market to the masses I think that our
demographic is a very similar
demographic as far as like I said this
sort of financial sovereignty and it's
just the belief system so that's why my
networking in the crypto space is
important to me because I think that the
opportunity will present itself
eventually as far as an actual use case
in our sport I've I've had my mind has
gone a different million different
directions and really
I would love to feel the ideas from
anybody that sees opportunities you and
I have had a lot of conversations that
you know one example could be the
fractional ownership side of things
and that doesn't necessarily have to be
limited to just a driver right in a
driver contract we've talked about
basketball players that or what's the
name of the best Spencer Dinwiddie
that's right Spencer Dinwiddie I mean
he's his attempt at at tokenizing his
contract
it sounds genius and it sounds you know
groundbreaking but it's really just
another version of what a lot of people
who are already doing behind the scenes
yep
you know golfers have staked themselves
with investors race car drivers have
staked themselves with investors there's
I think that blockchain provides up just
a technology that can more cleanly and
and and more cleanly define what those
investments look like but then also open
it up to a mass audience so I think you
could see racecar drivers doing that I
think that you could also see race teams
doing something like that so in NASCAR I
mean obviously we could have to have
permission from the sanctioning body
because the sanctioning body needs to
know who owns what but we are not a
totally a franchised business like the
NFL or NBA I mean the race the drivers
are still independent contractors
there's no Union the race teams
ultimately are our competitors yeah yeah
employers and independent organizations
so there's a lot of assets in the racing
industry that can be tokenized if that's
yeah fair thing to say I think it to me
it's how you could tokenize the
contracts of the drivers right you could
token us the ownership of the teams yeah
yeah there's even things that you can do
around somewhere how people are doing
like supply chain logistics yeah you can
do parts and I think you know so we have
and this is NASCAR's not totally unique
but we're you know we're an ecosystem
that does business with itself right and
in a lot of different ways so there's a
lot of money that is in NASCAR that
stays in NASCAR that's totally endemic
to NASCAR right you have money changing
hands from NASCAR to the team owners
going from the team owners to the
drivers
going back into NASCAR you know from the
Rick you know money coming from the race
fans let's say that's money outside of
NASCAR going into the racetracks and the
race tracks you know that the money
going to NASCAR at different forms so
there's even I mean there's there's tons
of opportunity for payment systems all
right say that's the holy grail is to
get NASCAR to accept Bitcoin yeah well I
mean I don't that's not I mean you you
talk about like like coin and align
payment systems and what they're doing
with the Miami Dolphins and you know all
the different services out there that
that have had over the last few years
have really figured out of efficient
ways to sell to settle payments in
cryptocurrency I give me a call and I'll
take you straight to the people in Ashe
car that that can make those decisions
because that's not unrealistic at all
you know but taking it a step further I
don't think I don't see why you know a
an industry like NASCAR couldn't have a
native payment system you know or in
native currency of its hand oil to know
this stuff for sure alright before
before we finish up I want to ask you
what I think of as frequently asked
questions that I've always had in my
head for NASCAR and for sure's but where
do I do I have to go pee uh-huh that's
actually one of the questions and so
just some people at home though we did
not prepare this he has no clue any the
questions I asked okay but the the first
question is what do you do when you get
when you're racing ready gotta pee
I always that one around I'm gonna make
this one quick okay I'm gonna turn that
one around on you
pump global a new sponsor of mine
funding Morgan Creek digital is on the
hood of the car multi-million dollar
investment yep we're we're we're in the
top ten of the Daytona 500 and there's
there's twenty laps to go in the race
you're on the edge of your seat on my
pit box and I come over the radio and I
say that I have to go pee yep not
happening
what do you want me to do keep driving
then pee in your pants
yep and that's just saying you got
there's no special assistance there's no
no fancy now I will tell you that I have
only have only had to pee my pants in a
race car one time what's ever yeah Wow
race cars yeah so the races are for
hours you know if you're smart you can
hold it yeah
really my thought process there is as
well don't overthink it so second
question and it'll go back to the first
question is our race drivers
professional athletes yeah absolutely I
yeah I tend to think that actually
people don't understand how difficult it
is both from a physical exertion
standpoint and the whole your body takes
and then also the sitting there going
you know 200 miles an hour right holding
the steering wheel yeah just car yeah I
mean you're holding a 3,000 pound car
and I mean so I wear a heartrate monitor
in the car I track my biometrics and my
god so my hobbies outside of racing are
endurance sports but it's not just a
hobby because I feel like it helps my
sport you know it's it's an investment
that I make in in my craft to compete in
endurance sports and my heart rate in a
four hour NASCAR race is actually you
could almost overlay it on my heart rate
on a four hour Half Ironman Triathlon
Wow so it's a very and and it's kind of
the same to a marathon it's very close
to a marathon heart rate over a four
hour marathon that's crazy yeah so it's
um I think I posted on social media one
one of the hotter races we had this
summer my average heart rate was like
145 for a three hour race
holy [ __ ] so the reason why I asked that
is as an athlete you've got stay
hydrated yep so you're drinking a bunch
of fluids you know anyone who's played
sports before finding the balance
between staying hydrated and not happen
to pee all the time yeah yeah yeah is a
balance so we lose about 15 pounds of
fluids in a race I'm able typically on a
on a race where I'm gonna lose that many
fluids I'm able to replace about 120
ounces in the car god I don't draw I
don't drink while I'm racing but when
there's brakes when there's caution
periods
I'll suck down a 20 24 ounce bottle like
it's
and I usually drink about you know five
or six okay so next question do you
bring your cell phone in the car during
the race
you're not allowed to not allowed to
okay so the texting and driving during
the race yeah
cellphones have accelerometers and I'm
and we're not allowed to have
accelerometers in the in the car why not
NASCAR has limitations on on the date of
the year allowed to collect in the car
on a race weekend so testing
environments it's pretty much wide open
or cars are not fitted with hundreds of
thousands of dollars of instrumentation
but on a race weekend it's there's a lot
of data collection in our car but it's
all sort of funneled through the NASCAR
got it what what is what do you bring in
the car with you for the race obviously
you bring some fluids or there are other
things that you bring that maybe people
wouldn't think about or is it just
pretty much fluid and then you get in
your fire retardant no I haven't let's
get racing yeah I mean my fire suit
shoes gloves helmet head and neck
restraints and I have a carbon fiber
bottle cage like you have on your bike
if you're a road cyclist or something
like that and and I drink out of a 24
ounce bottle and I do that instead of a
Camelback or like a mechanical system
burp because I like to keep track of how
much I'm drinking mm-hmm so I have that
right by the window of my car when I
come in for a pit stop there's a in a
pit stop you see the guys that run
around the car there's one guy that's
actually dedicated to the driver mm-hmm
his job is to get me whatever I need so
if I wanted a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich I'd ask him for one but I have
them put my drink mix in there and then
he'll pull a tear off the windshield to
clean to give me a fresh windshield very
cool what's the scariest situation
you've ever been in racing it's usually
I don't typically get scared and behind
the wheel I'm pretty used to it to the
to the fear factor of it all but usually
the the couple tenths of a second
between when your tire blows out and
you're headed straight to the wall is
this Guerette the scariest have you had
that happen yeah I had it happen a
couple months ago I blew a tire and
nathless Motor Speedway and hit the wall
at about 160 miles an hour hole and yeah
I was a pretty bad wreck and I was a it
was like a 35 G hit so if you could
imagine a 160 pound body turning into a
you know multiply that by 35 yeah that's
how much of a hammer that my body was
going into the wall dang not didn't it
didn't feel good I was I was sore for a
while like what when you got out of the
car was it something where you're like
hey I got pretty messed up there or yeah
I mean it well so you go to the infield
care center you see the doctors I have
to take a concussion test unfortunately
did not have a concussion but my I had a
lot of bruising on my body I had some
some rashes from like where the seat
belts you could if you know I wear
what's called a nine point harness so
there's nine points of anchoring on my
seat belts you could see the outline on
my body in bruising where my seat belts
are where they line up also it kind of
did his job though I did its job for
sure
about I was very sore I see excuse me I
see a physical therapist every Monday
after erase whether I need it or not
7:00 a.m. every every Monday and we just
go through my body and my mobility and
and that's kind of what kicks me off for
my training week so that I'm in so that
I'm ready to train after a wreck like
that I was saw my physical therapist
every day that week and I didn't train
at all yeah you know that's you're
talking about have some salt baths and
recovery for sure is rubbing racing
rubbing is definitely racing yeah yeah
what what is the the culture within
drivers around this right because I
think most people they don't they don't
get to see kind of the drivers
perspective
yeah so it looks like there's a lot of
jockeying and there's a lot of an
intentional kind of rubbing or buzzer is
a very physical sport when it comes to
the cars and drivers I feel like for the
most part you know we get along as
drivers off the track we're pretty
intense with each other on the track
there's a lot of mutual respect
especially at the top level in the Cup
Series the drivers have a lot of respect
for each other but we race each other
really really hard
and we have a lot of different ways that
we communicate with each other on the
racetrack based on how you race the
other drivers you can its if there's a
way to send messages and a way to like
what give me some examples well the one
of the most useful tools to send a
message to another driver is to stick
your middle finger out the window the
bird really said the bird goes a long
ways and it cuz it's gonna say a lot of
things and and really the that is
amazing vigor in which you that you send
the bird can send a lot of messages to
you know are you shaking your hand is it
a soft bird do you just and I'm not
joking yeah there's a but also I mean
you use your car I mean it's it's when
the caution comes out coming pulling up
alongside of somebody and and bumping
them you know can send the message that
that you didn't like what they did you
know sometimes drivers will pull up to
you and they'll try to cut your tire I
mean it's they you know our cars have
sharp edges on them and they want to rub
against you and they might cut your tire
they might rub rub on your car and put
some damage on your car that can hurt
your performance if they don't like what
you did I mean that's that's that's the
gritty part of NASCAR race it's an elite
level to use the car to pop your tire ya
know not being able to drive going you
know you go 50 miles an hour let alone
100 yeah I mean it's you know it's I've
gotten ya I'm not someone that likes to
wreck other people because I don't want
to get wrecked right and you know that's
true crypto trading as well yeah for
sure and so you know when you're when
you're when you're in a tickle fight
with another driver I mean the best way
to get your [ __ ] piled up is to just
start wrecking people but sometimes you
know for me the best way to send a
message or at least get what I wanted to
get out of it is just put damage on
their car like I'm not gonna wreck you
but I'll damage your car yeah because
it's gonna screw up your performance
your team is not gonna like it your car
owner is gonna cost him money and
you know it's like hey if you're gonna
screw with me I'll just damage your car
yeah and and there's ways that you can
do it without hurting your own car and
that's that's there's that's one of the
ways I guess the drivers communicate
with each other but the bird is always a
good place to start don't don't tell
anybody how to do it we don't need on
the freeway what's the last question and
then we'll talk about some aliens but uh
what um what's the craziest thing you've
done to train for driving man I mean
it's I have spent hours and hours behind
the wheel of race cars and and in the
simulator
you know our simulation tools are
actually not necessary driver training
tools as there are engineering tools but
when I worked for Hendrick Motorsports I
mean I've been in the car for six seven
hours straight without getting out you
know why because we were at a test and
we had a test plane and we had to get
everything done and we were beating the
daylight and you know those are those
are the tests where you're just you have
to you you're putting your life on the
line lap after lap after lap you have a
you know several hundred thousand dollar
racecar with that much more money
invested in the instruments that are on
it and you're driving in a two hundred
miles an hour and you have to do that
all day long and and it's all for the
greater good of building faster race
cars so I love it I feel like yeah I
feel like just the business itself is
the craziest thing you could do I mean
I've been grinding at this for a long
long time for sure before you get asked
me a question
aliens real or not I think I probably
listen to the Joe Rogan experience too
much to to not believe in aliens so uh
yeah I think aliens are real or I think
there's something I think there's
something living out there do you think
they've ever been dearth vision but
there's no contact I don't know you know
I think that in in my capitalist belief
and and the the maybe I capital me
wrong word to use what am I trying to
say what are we as human like sentient
bees yeah I think we're definitely
capitalist yeah we're definitely I guess
it like in the widget life in our in our
nature as humans it's it's hard not to
you know it's hard not to think that if
aliens were here for me that that they
would've taken us over if they are more
powerful than us mm-hmm right so I just
I don't know I have a hard time
believing that there's aliens out there
that are just watching us and yeah like
if they had the technology to know about
us and we didn't know about them then we
probably wouldn't be in existence know
what they might just be watching but
these idiots
I think stuff they're doing I can see
they're like maybe there's there's
life-forms out there that we're more
advanced than that we just haven't found
yet yeah I haven't found us if they were
watching anybody look us every Sunday
they still hoping they just drive around
a circle exactly awesome and well to
finish up what a one question you have
for me um one question that I have for
you oh my gosh how I mean how long is
this journey for you how long is this
this crypto journey Oh people already
know are you a crypto lifer is there an
exit someday is there uh yeah look so
there's two separate things one is the
technology the assets etc and then the
other is like what I was calling like
the media stuff so what are writing
everyday the podcast on the media side
one day I'm gonna wake up and I'm just
gonna say it was a fun ride but I'll see
you guys later yeah yeah I get seen a
trainer you may never hear from me again
um what are you reading right now
reading I'm actually reading Edward
Snowden's permanent record okay yeah yes
that one's pretty good
I just finished recently Steve
Schwartzman I think whatever it takes is
what it's called I know it's pretty good
but to me it's just that the media stuff
is it's fun and it's way to kind of
collect thoughts talking people's stuff
but uh it could be draining and at some
point I think I'll just be alright see
you yeah and it'll free up a lot of time
right it allowed me to go read more to
allow maybe I'm gonna do other
but uh but for right now I'm having fun
so we'll keep with that and they done
the investing side III don't think that
I could ever walk away so we'll see what
happens then nice thanks
awesome man all right well I appreciate
you doing this where can people find
find you online or find out more
information if they want to get in
contact with you I'm on Twitter Landon
Cassill at Landon Cassill LEM vo and Cas
si LL and my DMS are open so that's like
a Mississippi when you're a little kid
you learn oh yeah yeah and I'm on
Instagram as well so but crypto twitter
can find me on on Twitter I mean I
appreciate you doing this hey everyone
pop here if you like this episode of off
the chain and want to help us take
crypto to the top of the Apple Spotify
and other podcast charts please do us a
favor and rate review and subscribe to
review simply go to the off-the-chain
homepage scroll down until you see the
five blank stars taking 15 seconds to
fill those stars in and leave a quick
review goes a long way in helping us
take the entire crypto ecosystem to the
top of the charts I appreciate you
listening and see you next time on off
the chain